so when students come in to class on the
first day I think they usually expect to
walk in and start working on a dream
game right away and I don't think that's
just not going to happen they have a lot
to learn simply to learn about working
with the teammates figure out who else
is in the class and what skills they
bring to bear and chances are they
haven't really thought all that much
about the game design that they want to
make and usually the very first idea or
the idea that you've been nursing ever
since high school or something isn't the
best idea that for a single semester
project students often want to make the
big expansive epic RPG we get a lot of
students who want to make the next
legend of zelda maybe trying to remake
Skyrim but in 2d and they think they're
scoping it down but they're not so it's
one of the first things we're doing
especially the first couple weeks of the
class are just getting them to
understand what are the what's the the
scope of the game development project
but also just getting them to understand
how difficult it is to work in a team
how how much effort an individual needs
to put forward in order to to work
efficiently as part of a team especially
when it comes to a creative thing like
like game development and game design a
lot of students want to make their
personal project and the first thing
they need to do is realize that there
are other opinions on the team that have
other that should be respected and there
are some opinions that are going to be
stronger because there's more design
experience there so figuring out how to
balance those teams this is a biz it's a
big big step for them to take when they
start the biggest thing we want them to
learn when they come in and take the
course is how to work as a group on a
creative project almost everybody's
worked on a creative project before
people have worked in groups before but
working on a project where the group
together is setting the goal and the
goal is fluid because with a creative
project with a game design project what
you're making is always evolving as you
keep working on it and so being able to
as a group discuss those changes
acknowledge those changes work together
to get to something that everybody wants
to work on it every
is capable of working on and you are all
capable of getting done in the very
short amount of time you have to work on
these complex projects that's actually
one of our biggest goals you know one
one thing about creative projects is
that aren't not right answers you know
there's a lot of different ways that a
project can can go when you're basically
just trying to create an aesthetic
experience for the players and so
multiple people with different
viewpoints can all be right at the same
time and it's not like you're designing
a machine to solve a specific problem
and it problem is solved you know that
you've done your job and this can be
just can lead to a lot of ego and
clashes and arguments over basically a
something that is already difficult to
implement and every time you get into
those arguments you're actually taking
time away from the actual development of
the game yeah we try to give the
students the tools and methods they can
use to if they have an argument to
provide evidence for the argument and
often it comes down to testing out ideas
rather than having those those
discussions as a team using prototyping
methods using either paper if they've
just got the paper right there before
they've even written code just throw
something down on paper get another
person to look at it and then to see it
did it work or not and getting away from
from having the purse the personalities
involved getting away from having ego
involved in all this it's for first-time
designers for for the students that we
have if they don't have the evidence the
first thing you're going to go back to
is is personal he go which is not
there's not the way to do these things
it'll just cause further problems down
the line so the course is overall
organized with four four projects it's
all of our workers group work because we
are emphasizing how do you work together
on a team to solve a creative problem
all of our projects are group projects
and we grade primarily as a group our
project start from very small and scale
up too big so we have our opening
project which is
doing a paper prototype even a fraction
of a paper prototype it's not a full
game it's just sort of what are the Act
what are the main actions in the game
and that's about a two week project and
then we build up to okay you've got a
prototype form a new group a bigger
group this time we bout double our group
in size from three to six and turn that
into a digital game for the third
project you once again have that two
week time period but during the second
project we taught you our basic project
management schemes and some project
management skills using that second
project and as an example of how to do
that and on the third project we're
asking you to come up with your own game
design idea prototype it out and finish
it as a group using the project
management using all those project
management techniques that we taught
it's sort of our test run project for
the fourth project which is the final
project it lasts I think seven and a
half weeks and we double the group size
again up to eight we're actually
intentionally giving the students large
groups that are harder to work with and
their first thought is we've got all
these people we can make a huge project
and our and our responses you've got all
those people you're going to have to
figure out how you're all going to
communicate well together so you can
actually get something done and that's
sort of the final capstone project where
we give them a fairly tight set of
constraints but other than that they're
designing the design they're planning
out the project management ver in charge
of planning their testing sessions and
they're polishing systems and we we use
that time to check in with them and give
them feedback along the way but it
really is sort of like okay we've given
you the tools time to really practice
using them